one of our favorites Chris Weber back
here on the show how are you see Webb
what do you think of the Warriors last
night what you see what you see in your
eyes it's Groundhog Day I mean they led
the league in assists last year they
were right on point what about 28 last
night they made sure that they move the
ball around I got guys involved and you
know what we're really stuck out to meet
is Kevin Durant is so great I mean he's
we never seen anything like him but it's
just amazing that sometimes you can
forget how good stuff and clay are
because the land is so clear at least I
was just sitting last and I just
thinking curry is incredible but when
Durant has the ball is high his skill
set I mean these as a good and it it
taught me to see anybody I can stop my
juice sauce and your continuance of
their play selfish playing and the
teamwork do you think it still hurts
with the Thunder to see Durant in this
uniform because it sure looked like he
and Westbrook had some words last night
Chris yeah you know I think they've let
that go but I think it's still a beat
from what I mean by that is like hey
nobody's mad that you left and you
played you know we understand that we
did you did your thing and whatever beef
we had about that okay but now we have a
new beef and I still don't want y'all to
beat me like I don't think I don't think
Westbrook takes it anymore personal
durant than anyone else you know he's
kind of like Kobe to me in the fact and
other players there's maybe our place
within the fact that just you know I I
was like this when I play like I wasn't
friends with anybody
I may be yet four maybe five players in
NBA my whole my whole timing in yet so I
never was in these boys groups these
clubs cool with a bunch of agents and go
work out I didn't want that I didn't
come akan that was my favorite player
but I I told him like well I'll win a
crazy contest I don't care about getting
kicked up again we will be friends after
our careers and we are now I love I love
him but it was just somewhere a menace
is me against you and I think that
that's where Westbrook is with a guy
like Durant and Durant is against
everyone and uh it to me is kind of
refreshing to see knowing that they
really don't hate each other but they
don't like each other on the court
you know I like that component and it
seems though you know that's fine when
you do that against somebody from
another team seems like Jimmy Butler's
taken that approach with his own
teammates Chris from my perspectives I'm
wondering what you think yeah okay so
this one is intriguing show I used to
and we're not going to play with one and
other guys I remember one pack she
wanted I have where we would always
practice on the same team and we would
you know it was it was great we were
encouraging our team in Washington and
one day we kind of had to not I guess
not formulate book almost say I was like
I'm playing with the second team because
we're gonna beat ya'll the first team is
too late and he would say the same thing
and put it everyone knew that what we
were trying to do is make the third team
better and let guys know that you can
win with anybody and this locker room is
equal and those type of things so if
that was Jimmy Butler's goal to piss
people off and they say hey we can win
with this team great but if it was
anything else is just not cool like I
didn't like what he and ziwei did at
that time in Chicago saying the guys
don't play hard after the game damages
that was BS that's just throwing guys
under the bus and in this situation
I know Jimmy's a tough player I love
this game I love your story but how can
you have a successful locker room with
this but I hear everybody and I know a
lot of Hooper's don't like talking about
Hooper's and all that but this is a bad
situation you got young Wiggins there
everybody saying he doesn't play hard
nobody knows that I remember people said
that about Tracy McGrady because of his
body language so nobody knows if Wiggins
plays hard or not nobody knows a cat
plays hard not you know why cuz they
have a terrible office you could talk
about they were fourth all you want last
year teams playoff teams I was talking
to they're like we're gonna kill him in
the playoffs because they play regular
season basketball you can win and during
the regular season playing regular
season basketball wasn't impressed by
their one point win over Denver at home
to make the playoffs I wasn't impressed
by that so I think I think they're
feeling themselves too much I just I
don't
Michael Jordan on that team yet and I
think the town's is one of the best
young big men in the game and I'd like
to see this team be athletic I like to
see him get out and run I like to see
them get out of their way and so to me
Minnesota the last few years have been
my favorite team and my most hated team
because I love them because the
potential but you know they they just
they don't play like a good young team
and I think everybody the coach
everybody has to look at themselves and
say that they're part of it well I mean
what your colleague on Turner in his is
an area 21 I don't know if kg needed the
curse button or not but he said that
Glen Taylor the owner of the
Timberwolves doesn't know basketball he
might have said it and a little bit more
of a not-safe-for-work way and so what
if what if Butler is in a situation
where he's just trying to get out of
there Chris let him go like for him to
say Tibbs life stared and he liked the
fact I did this a practice that's be us
I gotta need my coach to be on my side
even when you're beating me up and
making me better so I'm just saying it
just doesn't feel right you starting the
season so what are your aspirations rich
but what are your aspirations if you're
in Minnesota clear to make the playoffs
so when the championship or just to get
to December and January I hope you don't
have to try to fight a teammate you got
families tweet another but like it's
just not a good situation like it's
almost like starting a marriage off you
know after you both try to kill each
other and then you make passionate love
it's how long it's gonna work what we
did last night our that doesn't matter
you know I mean like what where do you
go from here I don't know I don't you
know I was always the guy who had to try
to help control the locker room and for
me if we were friends like I never to
talk a little football don't worry I
didn't like how the offensive line did
levy on there I don't I never got on the
guy forgetting his money never you can
always go get your money is not a family
they'll trade you guys they're timeless
tomorrow go get your money okay that's
one thing but to talk about us and they
want to come back in the locker room and
then to tell stories to the media about
being all that not we don't have that
I'm gonna see you in the locker room so
I think that you know I maybe you know
maybe they're you know it's a different
day and they're better men and
all the men that have come before them
so how you do with Eagle and competitive
in the locker I don't I don't see how
this could work at all and it's there in
San Antonio tonight they open up in San
Antonio tonight I mean we'll see how it
goes and we'll see if Jimmy Butler's
there I mean crazy it really I haven't
seen anything quite like it and what
about what are they gonna say like now
what pressure did you put all cat like
what pressure did you put on weekly and
don't get me wrong at the end of the day
if I'm a Minnesota fan and Butler just
traded maybe he helped our team more
than any coach any GM
anyone could because what he said about
these guys is gonna linger with them
their whole career until they disprove
it and so maybe this is the fire that
you need to start it under them but you
can't have that guy around all the time
after you start the fire Chris oh yeah
yeah Chris wherever here on the Rich
Eisen show sorry I thought you were done
Chris Webber here on the Rich Eisen show
you're making your way to Portland
that's gonna be a heck of a moment when
obviously they remember Paul Allen
before that game and then it's gonna be
LeBron coming out in a Lakers uniform
what is the realistic expectation do you
think for LeBron in his first year with
the Lakers Chris Webber well this is you
know I think the only one that agrees
with me is Charles Barkley saw it I know
he's right a lot but then again he's
been epically wrong I don't know what
sighs but this is my thing and and I
just hoped fans really understand this
so let me start by saying this if the
Lakers make the playoffs
no one will appreciate how great LeBron
is this will be one of his best
accomplishments because this is the West
Coast you asking him to win 20 more
games in a conference where teams are so
good veteran teams and he has a team of
newcomers this first year we saw that he
couldn't win a championship and Miami is
for sure how hard is that once you get
guys together we've seen that with a lot
of different teams but yes he makes his
players better yes he's one of the
smartest players one of the greatest
players ever to play he's gonna energize
that community but I still see their
move being next year because I just have
a couple questions but
him who's gonna shoot three-pointers
mm-hmm I guess heart right I don't know
it's definitely not Lanza off the top of
my head's not Rondo down there down
three we double-team the bra who's gonna
shoot that the reporter all right Kuzma
can fill it up I mean wow so now with
the pin on the second year power forward
okay I'm just throwing these names on it
I'm just you know that's not the Shane
Battier Kyle Korver's you know Mike
Miller's you know the guys hit eight for
aid in the finals of Ray Allen's I'm
just saying that with talent specific
talent with this team that they have now
and I like the players that they have it
doesn't seem that they have the skill
sets to win in the West and of course
you know the link is my man and Magic's
my man so it's a profit we'll make
trades and help the team but as the team
stands today before their first game I
do not see how they're going to make the
playoffs in the rough West with the new
team and I just don't think they have
the shooters I think there's too many
ball handlers and that's not even the
eighth and final playoff spot with
LeBron I mean that would be based on
last year's standings the Lakers would
have to be plus 12 plus 12 in the win
column to get to the eighth and final
playoff spot if everything stayed from
last year's this year and based on based
on that then Denver who lost by one game
who I think is going to be a top four
team you got to give them ten more words
you know you got to take San Antonio
into consideration so I do think there's
a chance with injuries and things like
that but you know when you go to Denver
out and then on the Wednesday in
Portland on a Thursday those
back-to-back sku you but there's more
traveling on the west coast as I'm sure
many people understand you know when
you're traveling east you go from
Toronto to Cleveland hour and a half
hour flight you go to Texas after LA
game that's three and a half hours you
know it's just it's just all the little
intangibles along with duty make and
along with guys that LeBron being the
best penetrator in the game getting to
the lanes getting double and triple
teams but he kicks it out you still got
to knock the shot that you can say what
you want about JR Smith Kyle Korver
those
but they did knock those shots down and
I'm interested in see who's gonna step
up and knock him down because I love
Grand Am Ingram but he's a slasher you
know I see all slashes and want to see
besides the ground who can consistently
back down that few minutes left with
Chris Webber Turner Sports fresh off a
call name with Marvin Golden State last
night so our poll question is is which
team do you think is going to add the
best chance to prevent the warriors from
winning it all so we included the Lakers
so we'll throw that one out based on
your last answer celtics or rockets or
other chris which one old guns now I do
think LeBron is good enough I know this
all sounds kind of crazy I don't know if
he's good enough I don't know what this
team will be good enough to get to the
playoffs but they can be a couple of
teams in a seven-run seven-game series
but I can concentrate on they have time
to plan time to adjust so and they have
time they can do that but every day I
don't think they can and I think maybe
Houston because because Houston is in
the same conference arguably you can say
Houston could have won it last year with
the healthy Chris Paul I just think by
then losing Trevor Ariza Bob bootay I
think that's too much for them but in
this West Coast they set a record for
three's last year they love that Sony
style of play melo is reengaged has a
bunch to prove a cappella got paid he
should be happy and I not just the
Houston uh being that team all right
last one for you Chris is your honorary
captaincy for Jim Harbaugh's Michigan
Wolverines is coming up correct your
doing that yeah I am I'm still excited
on November 3rd gets Tuesday
hand-stained yeah are you are you gonna
dress the team you know that we're still
working out everything but yeah yeah I'm
gonna take I know you've done it before
I'm gonna take full advantage of every
opportunity to be with the team to speak
to those guys it's always good being
around young energy and pumping them up
and letting them know who they are and
that type of thing and just think about
you know we have a couple feet games but
you know we were in that game that could
be the culmination and some pretty great
things could happen after that if we win
it so I'm so excited to go back did you
see how beautiful it was the last
Saturday night when they when the lights
are on TV right and get the game on the
table so when I was getting goosebumps
they're talking to my father we
laughing and so long I'm excited I'm
pumped I can't wait but they Michigan
versus Michigan State before then and
you know firsthand what that means in
that state Chris you know yes I do and I
know that you got to respect the
Spartans and they have to respect both
because you know from a few years there
it seemed like every team will go
undefeated Ohio State Michigan Michigan
State and then the end for the season
one of those teams would beat the other
one to advance and so ya know you always
got a you know respect when we're
playing really saw some good ball our
office is coming together and you don't
want to mess with our defenses so I feel
good about where we are with Coach has
the keys and the confidence that they
have and and I'll be ready uh November
third to cheer loudly like I'm doing
something for it well I'll tell you this
too you know I've told you before I'll
say it here - I'm just excited you're
going back to campus and you're you're
you're injecting yourself into Michigan
Athletics Chris it's pretty cool
speaking on behalf of all Wolverines and
it's pretty um it's pretty cool to get
back into you know see my fellow
Wolverines and people who went to school
there and alumni I you know everywhere
long it's you know people from Michigan
you know we're so happy to have you back
and I always tell me not you're not
happier than me so I love it and I can't
same thing but I'm excited but I'll make
sure I take a lot of pictures and video
showing well because it's a portable and
you are happy about it you are happy
with the decision to go and do this
right Chris
correct oh yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't have done it if not and uh I
tell you what the most thing I'm worried
about and I talked to you about earlier
the the most pressure is I just want the
guys the room when I'm there you know
not like I can help them win or out to
lose but you don't want to be captain
you chose it you chose a good one Chris
I love our chats I'm excited that the
season is back and I hope that means we
get to chat a lot more often you got it
Thanks as Chris Webber at real Chris
Webber the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience